So now we understand our persona for our pizza app, Dorm
Room Debbie. We know all about her attributes and we understand
her use cases. So in a minute we're going to talk about
how we can build feature lists that are perfect for Debbie.
>> Yeah but before we do that though let's address the elephant in the room.
>> We actually didn't have an elephant so
we got this thing instead. The Abominable Snowman?
>> Yeah.
>> So where did these persona attributes and use cases come from?
>> How to we validate that they're
representative of actual users in the real world?
>> Well,
the way we do that is there's an
entire field called UX research which does just that.
>> There are folks that go out in the world and
they use a variety of tools like interviewing people, observing their behavior.
>> They have things hypnography and they figure what people
do, what tasks want to perform with technology in their
daily lives and what they expect from this technology. Exactly,
so they give us all the data to help us build
the really informed personas in news cases so we
know that our designs are going to be really accurate.
>> Yeah and we're going to see a video just now from Rich
that talks about UX Research and why it's important and how it's done.